اعتقد كما قدمت انه لا يمكن او لا يوجد
شخص على وجه الارض يمكن ان يتحدث عن ملف
اوكرانيا ونيته وروسيا من وجهه نظر
امريكيه مثلك انت في اكثر فتره حساسه في
العلاقات بين الاتحاد السوفيات السابق
والولايات المتحده كنت انت المسؤول الاول
في الاداره الامريكيه عن ملف اوكرانيا
روسيا وروسيا وهذا يدفعني للسؤال الاول هل
كنت تتوقع النصر الى ما وصلنا اليه اليوم
الماضي
عام 93 لم نتوقع ابدا ان نرى الحرب
الحاليه
دي كوانيا
الاتحاد السوفيتي
الثالث اكبر الترسانه في العالم عام 94
اوكرانيات تخلت عن هذه الترسانه بشكل
اساسي لان روسيا التزمت باحترامي سياده
اوكرانيا
الاتص
وزاره الخارجيه وكنت واعمل مع مجلس الامن
القومي في البيت الابيض كانت هنالك
اتصالات جيده جدا
بين الرئيس الابا ورئيس روسيا السن وحتى
بين رئيس
عام 98 او 99
بوتن لم يكن عامل مؤثرا وفي منتصف الاول
لم تصل الى المستوى الذي تمنيناه